The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
AMY BANZAERT: Welcome.
I'm really excited.
This is the second year
of this class [INAUDIBLE]
and that I've been teaching it.
So hopefully a little
bit of the growing pains
have been worked out.
It should be a fun, good class.
So today, we're going
to talk about a bunch
of different stuff.
It's all kind of high level,
and most of this class
is pretty low-level detail.
And this is high
level to give you
the macro view before we dive
into the more detailed stuff.
The way I think about it
is it's like a toolbox
of stuff you'll need
every day in this class,
either in the back of your
mind or the front, depending.
So it's just these
random bits and pieces.
And I apologize.
There's no good
way to make it be
any more cohesive than it is.
But hopefully,
it'll hang together.
So we're going to talk
about energy in the world
generally, review units,
review a little bit of EE,
do a little bit of estimation
practice, which we'll
do almost every time
we meet, and then
just talk about the class and
homework and stuff like that.
And I forgot my
dongle today, so I'm
working off of two computers.
I apologize if that
gets too crazy.
OK, so if you can
grab the document that
has a graph on the
top-left corner,
we're going to go
through what life
is like using a bunch
of different development
indicators we got from the World
Bank in different countries.
And the countries I
picked are Nicaragua
because that's the country
where this class travels
to over spring break--
and I'll talk more
about that later--
Haiti because it's the
poorest country in the Western
Hemisphere--
and so pretty close, and
it's been in the news a lot
because of some of the
tragedies they've had.
United Arab Emirates
because this class
is also taught at Masdar
Institute of Science
and Technology there and is also
a differently very developed
nation; the US
because that's where
we are, China because they're
also in the news a lot,
and then the DR
Congo, which the--
deciding who is the poorest
country in the world
is a kind of impossible
task because it depends
on what you count what
it is, but DR Congo
ranks as one of them.
So you can see already there's
some pretty severe differences
in these different
countries in terms
of the population,
the service area,
and then the resultant
population density, which
you can imagine is going
to have a big impact
on the quality of life.
So I'll leave it at
that, and then we'll
draw conclusions at the end.
So now we're going to do what
I would call a ludicrous quiz
because it's going
to be difficult.
So the way you do this and
we're going to do together
is first try to guess what
the biggest number should
be on the y-axis.
So what's the largest GNI
per capita in US dollars?
And throw out some numbers.
GNI is the average
income a person makes,
Gross National Income.
AUDIENCE: $30k.
AMY BANZAERT: So $30k.
Anyone want to say higher?
AUDIENCE: $45k.
AMY BANZAERT: 45.
Can we go higher, lower?
OK, and what do you think
the worst-case scenario is?
What are the poorest
people making?
AUDIENCE: $5.
AMY BANZAERT: $5?
Anyone more optimistic
than $5 per year?
OK.
And then best guess on who is
going to be the one up here?
This should be fast--
AUDIENCE: US.
AMY BANZAERT: --fun.
I won't judge you.
[LAUGHS]
AMY BANZAERT: All
right, guess for US.
Anyone want to
guess someone else?
OK, and the poorest?
AUDIENCE: Haiti.
AMY BANZAERT: Haiti.
OK, so now-- no, that one.
All right, so in
reality, US, yup,
you guys did great with those.
$5 is a little low by an
order of magnitude or two.
And Haiti is the poorest country
in the Western Hemisphere
but not in the world.
That would be Congo
or one of them.
And so, yeah, they're
in fact, the lowest.
All right, so now it's
going to get harder.
So what percentage of people
have improved access to water?
This one, we don't have
to worry about the y-axis
because we're talking
about percentages.
So we we're at 100%.
So let's take-- who do you
think has the best water quality
access?
And what percentage
of people have access
to clean water in that country?
AUDIENCE: I'd say it's the US.
AMY BANZAERT: The
US, and how much?
AUDIENCE: 99%.
AMY BANZAERT: 99%,
so basically 100%.
Anyone want to be a different
country or more pessimistic?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Maybe a
little less than 100%.
AMY BANZAERT: A
little less than 100%?
OK, and then who do you
think has the poorest?
AUDIENCE: Congo.
AMY BANZAERT: The Congo?
OK.
So let's go check this out.
So the UAE actually beats the
US in terms of clean water.
And we actually forgot
to ask the percent.
I forgot to ask the
percentage, so oops on that.
But I think, generally, it's
higher than people guess.
However, these
numbers are always
complicated in terms of what
does that actually mean.
And does having access to clean
water mean 100% of the time?
Are the people
collecting the data
actually getting good data?
Or is there a bit
of cheating going
on to make your country
look better than it is,
which happens a lot?
So these aren't necessarily
things to be confident on.
One of the things I
find really interesting
is that China and Nicaragua
are almost at the same level.
And Nicaragua is a much,
much poorer country
in a lot of other
measures than China.
OK, next, improved sanitation.
So who do you think has
the best and at what level?
AUDIENCE: Probably UAE again.
AMY BANZAERT: UAE, and how much?
AUDIENCE: 90%.
AMY BANZAERT: 90%?
UAE.
Anyone else?
This is a class where
it's great to participate,
and you don't need to be
shy about guessing wrong
because we're all guessing here.
This is not a type
of thing you're
going to know off
the top of your head.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
improved sanitation?
AMY BANZAERT:
Improved sanitation.
So unimproved sanitation
is you poop in a hole,
and maybe that hole
goes down to the river
and pollutes your river.
Maybe it's behind your
backyard and just sits there.
Maybe you don't
even have a hole.
So this would be
improved to a level
that the World Bank considers
it actually making a difference
in terms of people's health.
And if you go to the
World Bank website,
it explains it more succinctly
and more tactically than I can.
AUDIENCE: So would it
include [INAUDIBLE]??
AMY BANZAERT: Exactly.
So and again, this
is for urban access,
not for rural access
because, in rural areas,
you can have a deep
hole, and that'll
work fine if it's dug
in the right place,
whereas if you are in
an urban environment,
there's just too much population
density for that to work.
So any other guesses
for best case?
AUDIENCE: US.
AMY BANZAERT: The
US, and how much?
AUDIENCE: 99%.
AMY BANZAERT: 99%,
OK, and then what
do you think the low bar is?
AUDIENCE: Haiti.
AMY BANZAERT: 80%?
Oh, you said Haiti?
AUDIENCE: Haiti.
AMY BANZAERT: Haiti,
OK, and I'm sorry.
And these numbers are all
from before the earthquake,
so it's worse now in Haiti.
And what percentage
do you think in Haiti?
AUDIENCE: 50%.
AMY BANZAERT: 50%?
OK, so, 50%, 30%, 20%,
somewhere in there.
OK.
So Haiti does
indeed win this one,
and this was before
the earthquake,
so it's worse now, as I said.
A lot of that has to do
with population density
that Haiti is just so dense
that it's really hard to manage.
There's more people
in the urban areas
than there are in
most other countries.
And here, the USA is
a little bit better
than the UAE in
terms of sanitation.
There's a sheet that I'll hand
out that has all of these,
so you can write it
down if you want,
but you don't have to
frantically record everything.
Sorry to not warn
you of that earlier.
OK, so energy use in
kilograms of oil per person--
so now you don't
get the easy 100%.
So these are getting
harder, as I mentioned.
So how many kilograms
of oil do you
think a person in the US uses?
AUDIENCE: Per year?
AMY BANZAERT: Per year.
AUDIENCE: 300.
AMY BANZAERT: 300?
Price is Right, Hi Lo, anyone?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: All right,
throw out a number.
AUDIENCE: 1,000.
AMY BANZAERT: 1,000?
Anyone want to go up an
order of magnitude or down?
So by that, I mean
going up to 10,000
instead of 1,000 or 100,000.
When it's just crazy numbers
where you don't really
have a good sense, it's kind of
meaningless to say, 300 or 400.
They're all as meaningful as
10 or 100 or 1,000 or 100,000.
Any other-- are guys
happy with this?
OK, UAE, USA, someone else?
AUDIENCE: China.
AMY BANZAERT: China?
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: US.
AUDIENCE: The US.
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
AUDIENCE: UAE has oil, and it
doesn't have that many people,
so technically--
AMY BANZAERT: So they
could be using a lot too,
so those are all possibilities.
All right, on the
low end, what do
you think the lowest number
might be of kilograms of oil?
AUDIENCE: Congo [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: Congo.
AMY BANZAERT: 100?
AMY BANZAERT:
Congo, and how much?
AUDIENCE: 12.
AUDIENCE: 10.
AMY BANZAERT: 10?
Anyone want to go to 1 or 100?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
So there's a lot
that we use, way off
by an order of magnitude.
We're at about 10,000
is where we are.
Again, these are a few years
old, so China is catching up,
but it's nowhere near where
the US or the UAE is yet.
And then Haiti and
DR Congo were-- you
guys were low by an
order of magnitude.
So even in the
poorest countries,
there's still a
decent bit of oil
being used for a variety
of energy purposes.
So with oil and all the
other things comes emissions.
So what do we think
is the emissions?
This is getting again
even harder to guess.
Metric tons per capita of
carbon dioxide emissions-- so
how many metric
tons do you think
you are responsible
for each year,
assuming you're the
average American?
1,000, 10,000, 100,000, a
million, a billion, a trillion?
AUDIENCE: 100,000.
AMY BANZAERT: 100,000?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: I'm sorry?
I heard a number.
AUDIENCE: 1,000.
AMY BANZAERT: 1,000, all right.
Anyone want to go above 100k?
OK, and then what about the low?
That should be relatively easy
because it should scale, right?
So if we know that,
on the previous graph,
10,000 was that high energy,
and 100 was the low energy,
then we should be two orders
of magnitude smaller, right?
So let's see if that works.
But that means we'll
be between 1k and--
1,000 minus two 0's is 10.
Yeah.
So who wants to guess
where the high and low is?
Where?
What countries?
AUDIENCE: USA is highest.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: China [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: China's high.
Low?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
So Congo is indeed low.
It doesn't even register.
And metric tons is a
big number, so you guys
are nice and high on that.
[LAUGHS] We're talking about
10 rather than a zillion.
And the UAE again is
winning over the USA.
And China was not
competitive yet.
I don't know that
they are yet either.
OK, so electric
power consumption.
Let's do this one fast.
So kilowatt hours-- do
you guys have any sense
of what a kilowatt hour is?
Can anyone give a
physical example?
AUDIENCE: It's a bit like the
amount of power required to run
a light bulb for an hour.
AMY BANZAERT: So
a kilowatt hour--
so thinking about light
bulbs is a great approach.
So kilowatt hour-- so, yes, so
definitely how much in an hour.
Do how many watts a
typical light bulb is?
AUDIENCE: 60.
AMY BANZAERT: 60.
So it wouldn't be one
light bulb, right?
It would be 60 times 10 to
get to 600 to get times 2
basically to get
to kilowatt hours.
So that would be 20
light bulbs in an hour.
So how many--
AUDIENCE: Per person?
AMY BANZAERT: Per person.
Or is it per person?
Yeah, how many
orders-- there's 20.
How many sets of 20
light bulbs are we
powering each year per person?
AUDIENCE: 1,000.
AMY BANZAERT: 1,000?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] 100,000.
AMY BANZAERT: 100,000 And low?
AUDIENCE: 50.
AMY BANZAERT: 50?
OK, so I'm going to stop
worrying about countries
because it's getting a
little bit repetitive.
So in between, you
guys were spot on.
[LAUGHS] And here, the USA
does come ahead of the UAE,
naturally because the UAE is
loaded with oil, and we're not.
So we do use more coal generally
and a little bit of nuclear
to fire our plants,
but mostly coal.
And you can see that, in
this case, Haiti is very low
down, even compared
to the Congo,
in terms of how much
electricity they're using.
And you can infer how much
electricity there's access to.
Mobile cellular subscriptions.
So this is no longer
getting quite so ridiculous
in terms of numbers
that we can't imagine.
So on the high end, how many
mobile subscriptions per person
do you think there are?
AUDIENCE: Is this a
percentage [INAUDIBLE]??
AMY BANZAERT: So per 100 people.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: So 80.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's just--
AMY BANZAERT: So this
is the population.
I assume they go with like--
they don't go to infants.
I assume they go to
starting with people
who might have a cell
phone, but I actually
don't know that answer.
That's a good question.
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
AMY BANZAERT: Like 90, 100?
AUDIENCE: 90.
AMY BANZAERT: OK, and
who do you think wins?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: US.
AUDIENCE: China.
AMY BANZAERT: US,
China anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Congo.
AMY BANZAERT: Wins?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
And then on the
low end, how many?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] 30.
AMY BANZAERT: 30?
Anyone want to go lower
or higher on the low end?
AUDIENCE: 10.
AMY BANZAERT: 10, 5.
OK, and who do you
think is on the low end?
AUDIENCE: Haiti.
AMY BANZAERT: Haiti, who else?
OK.
So this one's
pretty interesting,
and this is year to year.
So in 2008, there were more than
two cell phone subscriptions
per person in the UAE.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
AMY BANZAERT: [LAUGHS] So
they like their phones there.
In the US, we're not
quite at 100 yet.
But we're getting
close to everyone
having a cell phone on average.
And there is that "some
people have more than one
phone" issue.
But you can see
that, in every place,
there's a pretty
strong growth curve.
And that's why the
cell phone companies
are raking in the bucks
right now worldwide.
Like, Haiti going from 1 to 34--
that's a pretty
phenomenal growth.
And everyone, even the Republic
of Congo, is doing pretty well.
Though, thinking
they were at the top,
I'm afraid is not the case.
But certainly the growth
rate in developing countries
is really high because people
are getting cell phones
before they get a lot of
other more developed devices.
And then lastly, internet users.
so what's your best guess there?
AUDIENCE: 90.
AMY BANZAERT: 90?
US, UAE?
AUDIENCE: Does
this include access
to the internet [INAUDIBLE]?
AMY BANZAERT: I don't know.
I think this study was probably
done before that was quite as
prevalent.
Because even in 2008,
you were using your phone
for internet access a whole lot
less than you're doing in 2011.
But let's say-- I
actually don't know.
So I can't even say,
"let's say something."
But, yeah, I'm not
grading you on this,
so it doesn't really matter.
It's just to give a sense.
So what-- 90, does anyone
want to take a different?
And then on the low end?
AUDIENCE: 20.
AUDIENCE: 1.
AMY BANZAERT: 20, 1.
OK.
So here, you can see that we're
pretty far behind in terms
of internet versus
cell phones, which
isn't all that surprising.
So the US is lower, the
UAE is a whole lot lower.
And in the developing
countries--
like Republic of Congo,
you might remember,
I think they were at 14 people
had cell phones per 100.
And they're at half
a person per 100.
So internet access
is a whole lot lower.
And you can think about
the reasons for that,
and they probably make
sense why it's harder
to get internet access than cell
phone access in a developing
country.
So that was our ridiculous quiz.
What might you take away
from trying to guess
those ridiculous things?
AUDIENCE: We need
more D-Lab classes.
AMY BANZAERT: You need more
D-Lab classes, absolutely.
I'll support that.
What else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Developed
countries really
contribute to global issues.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, developed
countries absolutely do.
I don't think that'll
come as a shocker
to anyone who's read the
newspaper in the past five
years.
But, yeah, but it's helpful
to see the actual numbers
as opposed to just a
gut sense, totally.
What else?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE:
--technologies, like when
you have cell
phones [INAUDIBLE],,
there's a possibility of
something else [INAUDIBLE]..
embrace it and use
it for two years.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah,
so a technology
that actually really
works for people
is going to be
embraced, absolutely.
And one like an
internet workstation
may not be one that is
embraced because it's
impossible to embrace.
So that's a good takeaway too.
One thing I take
away from this is
that there's not much
gut instinct here for me
either that we talk about
metric tons of carbon dioxide
emissions.
We talked about all these
different things in the news.
But do we actually, as MIT
scientists and engineers, who
are some of the brightest people
in the world on these sorts
of topics, know these details?
Heck no.
So when you're starting
to think about what
it means to do this work
in a developing country,
making assumptions like how
many cell phone users there are,
or how many internet
users there are,
or any other detail about life
is a pretty dangerous thing
to make an assumption on.
And you have to get the data
in order to do good work.
There are some trends with
poverty that we can take away.
So you did see
Nicaragua, the Congo,
and Haiti were always
on the lower end
compared to the more developed
countries are looking at.
But Haiti, Nicaragua,
and the Congo all
took turns who was the lowest.
And so even though you
can very distinctly
say who is making the
least income per capita,
that doesn't
necessarily translate
to who has the fewest cell
phone subscribers or something
like that.
And the last thing
is when you watch--
yeah, do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
But I was just going
to say that takeaway
was the opportunity that these
countries are developing,
though.
And so we're enabling
them to [INAUDIBLE]
and while that's
another thing, it'd
be great if they never
developed [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: That
sure would be,
and that's one of the challenges
for doing this type of work
is everyone pretty much
wants, hypothetically,
to lead a life where
everyone has a car,
and everyone has air
conditioning running or heat
running 24/7 like we do.
And if we try to create
our environment worldwide,
we're not going to have
a world for very long.
One other takeaway I have is
that you can get an assumption
if you've never traveled to
developing countries when you
see the photos of charity
for commercials and stuff
like that of how hard life is.
You can assume that
life is completely dire
and that 0% of people have
access to clean water,
0% have access to electricity,
no one has a cell phone,
and that's not true either.
And so you neither want to
assume that everyone has this,
but you don't want to assume
that life is impossible,
and everyone's living in the
Dilbert mud universe, where
all you have is mud, and that's
it, which is easy to happen
if you've never
traveled, and all you see
are Save the Children ads on TV.
Not to bash Save the Children,
but their ads are pretty stark.
[LAUGHS] This is tough.
OK, one other way to
think about development
is just to look at
the world at night,
which NASA does by
compiling a bunch of photos
of pictures at night.
And so you can very quickly
see where lights are
and where the wealth is, the
drawback being that fire also
creates light, and so areas
where there are big fires
will also look like
they're well developed.
And so that's often the case
that, in Africa, there's
fires burning out of
control, and that's
why it looks like
it's developed.
But just a kitchen
fire is not going
to show up on a NASA
graph, but it's an easy way
to think about where our
population centers in developed
countries and then also
where is enough money to have
electricity, to have lights.
So you can see things like
India is actually pretty lit,
and that plays out in terms
of how India is doing.
Its really been skyrocketing
in terms of its development,
and so there's a
lot more electricity
there than there was,
though there's certainly
plenty of work to be
done in that country
to make life easier.
Was there a question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was
going to say, does
the map like that [INAUDIBLE].
And it kind of looks the same.
AMY BANZAERT: [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: And somehow
you have this--
like even China right
now is pretty dark,
which is quite surprising
'cause you expect to China to be
more like [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: The same with
Facebook, actually.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Well, and
it's kind of fascinating.
I think in every
developing country,
there's not an even
distribution of wealth.
Just like in this country,
you've got your Bill Gates
and Warren Buffetts,
and you have
people who are starving
to death in this country.
You have that true
in every country.
In Haiti, you can see mansions
and you can see hovels.
And you can see that everywhere.
And so there's always going
to be that uneven distribution
wherever you go.
So Nicaragua-- why
did I pick Nicaragua
as the place to travel?
Well, it's a pretty great place
in terms of renewable energy
sources.
So you can see that it has
a lot of different sources.
It has wind on the coast.
It has a bunch of volcanoes,
which provide geothermal energy
that they're taking
advantage of,
rivers that can
provide hydropower,
solar energy because it's
basically on the equator,
and they grow sugarcane,
so you can grow ethanol.
So it's this really
nice place in terms
of lots of opportunity,
as compared
to some other
countries where there's
fewer natural resources.
And so if you want to
start in a country,
it's nice to start
in one where you
have something to start with.
But Nicaragua is the second
poorest country in the Western
Hemisphere behind Haiti.
And, yes, Haiti is well
behind Nicaragua, and more so
after the earthquake.
But Nicaragua still
has a lot of need.
I forget exactly when, but about
10 or 15 years ago Nicaragua
was about 70% renewable energy.
And as people's desire
for energy has gone up,
and the cost of
oil has stabilized,
they've actually sunk
back down to about 30%
renewable energy, which is a sad
thing-- especially considering
that Costa Rica, I think, is
about 90% or 95% renewable
energy.
So it can be done.
Costa Rica is a next-door
neighbor to Nicaragua.
When their goal is, by 2013,
which is getting ever closer,
they want to be at 3% oil,
which is pretty ambitious, given
that they're at
about 70% right now.
But that translates to there's
a lot of interest in Nicaragua
to use renewables.
So that makes doing work in
that country easier as well.
They're also close
by because we're
traveling over spring break,
and that's a very fast trip.
The idea of flying
all the way to Africa
and spending half
your time in the air
and spending all of your
budget on the airplane tickets
is not a great idea, so
that's the other reason
Nicaragua is of interest.
OK, so let's talk a
little bit about energy.
So we talked a little
bit about how much
energy is used worldwide.
So let's talk about
where it's coming from.
And you can see that coal
and oil really dominate where
our energy is coming from.
And all these renewable
energies that we talk about
are pretty microscopic.
So the world has a long way
to go before we can actually
reduce our greenhouse gas
emissions and things like that.
There's a really big
problem with this slide.
Does anyone see it?
[LAUGHS]
AMY BANZAERT: Email
me if you find it.
[LAUGHS] I'll give
you extra credit.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't add up?
AMY BANZAERT: Say again?
AUDIENCE: Does it not add up?
AMY BANZAERT: It does add up.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
So and now, exergy and--
for the purposes
of right now, you
can consider exergy and energy
to be basically the same thing
in your head.
That's a total lie.
And if you know
anything about exergy,
you know I'm lying
to you, but it's not
that critical to think
about the difference.
And so you can see where
are we spending our energy.
And it's actually
pretty well distributed
between all the different
needs, not entirely.
Others are carefully constructed
to be about the same size.
But what this means
is we can't just
somehow magically replace
all the cars in the world
and solve all our
energy problems
or somehow magically
stop needing agriculture
and have no more greenhouse
gas emission problems.
There's a lot of
issues worldwide
that need to be
addressed, and they all
need to be taken into account.
OK, so and why is it
so hard to switch?
Well, the energy density of
what we're used to using--
so diesel and
gasoline and such--
are awesome compared to
batteries, flywheels,
compressed air,
some of the things
that we talk about as being
the great alternatives.
And so going from something
that's an order of magnitude
worse and is harder to
come by is not an easy sell
because it means it's going to
be a whole lot more expensive
and less pleasant to use.
So that's why this is
such a difficult problem.
But because we're running out
of those really awesome ones,
we're going to have
to figure it out.
OK, so units check-in.
So one of your sheet says
"Units Check-in" on it.
And so you can pair up
preferably with someone
you don't know and
go through the units.
Again, I'm not going
to grade you on this,
but I would like to have you
turn it in with your name
so I know where the class stands
overall on this knowledge.
And you guys can work in teams
and just turn one sheet in.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AMY BANZAERT: This is an area
where-- oh, let me grab one--
where, hypothetically, we
should all know every answer
is members of the MIT community.
I know there's a couple
of people from Harvard,
so maybe you get a pass, but--
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Because
you're not necessarily
an engineer or scientist.
I wasn't trying to slam Harvard.
But these are
actually things that--
there's a few in here that are a
little subtle, like inductance,
that you're not going
to need to know.
That was just to check
how everyone is doing.
But most of them-- torque,
work, power, energy, pressure,
resistance--
those, you should know.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Are you out?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: I think we
need more because--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AMY BANZAERT: Oh.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: So
those are things
that are all really useful to
know for the rest of your life.
It's really handy to know
how energy and power relate,
what is energy, what is power,
and something that most people
don't know, including
engineers and scientists,
and is an embarrassment to our
educational system that most
of us don't.
So I hope that,
through this class,
you will be forced to get it
into your brain for long enough
that it'll stick.
So, yeah, definitely
learn that stuff.
All right, so what is energy?
Anyone?
You've got your units
in front of you.
Maybe that'll help.
AUDIENCE: A measure
of potential work.
AMY BANZAERT: Measure
So then what's the difference
between work and energy?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: So energy
is the ability to do work.
Anyone else?
The measure of potential
work, did you say?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
And then what's work, then?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: I can't hear
you back there, sorry.
AUDIENCE: Force over
distance [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: Force
over distance.
OK, can you give me something
that's a little more intuitive?
Because I don't have
a great intuition
of force over distance,
though, kind of I do.
I think I could work that out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you're
required to [INAUDIBLE]
over a distance [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, OK.
So the thing that confuses me
about that is you said, work
is force over distance.
And then you said,
it's the energy
to move an object
over a given distance.
So then I would think
the equation should
be E over d, not F over d.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --force applied over
a distance [INAUDIBLE] force
into [INAUDIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: OK, so
force over a distance.
[LAUGHS] OK, cool.
Any other definitions?
OK, so the way
that Saul Griffith
likes to think about it-- and
I took these slides from him.
He's an MIT alum who does a
lot of work in energy realms,
as well as design and
other great stuff--
is it's thinking
about lifting an apple
from the ground to a table.
So does anyone know how
much an apple weighs?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: A newton?
Yeah, that's a
really good guess.
Does anyone know how
much a newton is?
[LAUGHS] So, well--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Well, so
a kilogram and a newton
relate, and how do they relate?
AUDIENCE: 1 kilogram per newton.
AMY BANZAERT:
Yeah, so we're just
talking about mass
versus weight, right?
So mass is disregarding
gravity, and weight
is regarding gravity.
And so a newton is taking
into account gravity.
But, yeah, an apple
is about half a pound,
which is about a newton.
So I have two
apples here, so you
can get a physical intuition
for that because physical--
so just pass them around.
Physical intuition is
really, really handy.
And I know the
lengths of my thumb
so that I know how long an
inches and how long 7 inches is
and hopefully have some sense
of weights and distances too.
So that's why it's really
nice to have an equivalent.
And you can even take that apple
and feel what it physically
feels like to lift that apple
from the ground to a table.
And because a table
is about a meter--
so we're talking about
a newton-meter, which
is your joule.
So then what is power?
AUDIENCE: Energy
for a given time.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, exactly.
So we could think
about how many--
the watts associated with
moving a bunch of apples
from the ground to a table.
So moving 40 apples from
the ground to a table
is 40 watts, which is the power
associated with a light bulb.
And so light bulbs are
using a good bit of work
if you think about
how much work it
takes to move 40 apples from
the ground to the table.
You can do it, but
you wouldn't want
to do it all day every day for
as long as your lights are on.
AUDIENCE: Also [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Right,
right, for a second, yeah.
So you're doing
that every second
if you're powering your
light bulb hypothetically.
So does that make
sense to everyone?
If this is a good
analogy for you, awesome.
Use it.
Keep it in your head.
If it's a terrible analogy
for you, which it probably
is for some of you,
get creative and think
about what might be a
good analogy for you.
You can google on the web.
There's lots of different
people who explain
this in lots of different ways.
But these are two concepts
that is really good
to have in your mind.
The other one that
I like to do, which
is a little obscure in some
respects but really helps me,
is to recall that power is
analogous to a velocity,
and energy is analogous
to a distance.
So that's another way to think
of it in addition to the apple
analogy.
And however you're
thinking about it--
so running that Apple laptop--
I don't know what
this HP or IBM takes.
But it takes about 60 watts.
So it's moving 60
of those apples
every second for as
long as I keep it on.
The other way to think
about in addition to apples
is light bulbs.
Because, again, we have
light bulbs as a quantity
that we kind of know, and we
know that powering a light bulb
is a whole lot easier
than powering a toaster
oven or a space heater.
So you can kind of
think in those terms.
So when someone says something
is a kilowatt generator,
you can think of
what we did before.
You can think about how many
light bulbs in a kilowatt.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Would a
light bulb [INAUDIBLE]
is really more powerful.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, so
energy and power are--
the difference is whether you're
thinking about time or not.
So energy, if you think about
it in terms of distance,
I can say that I
walked a mile today.
And you can say, great.
And if I did it in four
minutes, you can say, wow.
And if I did it
in four hours, you
can say, unimpressive, right?
And so energy is
just telling you
that the equivalent of
how many miles you walked,
and power is telling you
how quickly you did it.
Both are really important.
So a light bulb that's
40 watts is telling you
how much energy is
going to be required
in a given amount of time to
turn it on, to keep it on.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: It's confusing.
I promise you I will
screw up and say
the wrong word occasionally.
And if you do, and you catch
me, I really appreciate it.
So all right, so let's do--
oh, sorry, are there any
questions about all of this?
It's hard to think about.
I've been in grad classes where
students screw it up royally.
So don't be saddened if you do.
But it is really important
to get a good intuition on it
in any energy class,
and hopefully,
as every engineer
or scientist will
have one by the end
of their career here.
Any other questions?
OK, so hopefully this equation
looks familiar to everyone.
Is there anyone who doesn't--
I know this is awful
to ask, but is there
anyone this doesn't
look familiar to?
Because this deals
with something
that is an assignment
that's due tomorrow.
So if it doesn't
look familiar, I
need to give you a different
assignment, because that's not
fair.
So if it doesn't look
familiar, and you
don't want to embarrass
yourself right now--
or not embarrass yourself,
but be open about it--
let me know after class.
So what's the V?
AUDIENCE: Voltage.
AMY BANZAERT: And
what's voltage?
AUDIENCE: Joules per coulomb.
AMY BANZAERT: I
couldn't hear all that.
So voltage is what--
is joules per coulomb?
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Difference
in potential
between the two terminals.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
The difference in potential.
I apologize about
my handwriting.
And can you think of the
analogy, the classic analogy
for voltage?
AUDIENCE: Water pipe stuff.
AMY BANZAERT: You said,
water pipe stuff, yeah.
So what's voltage?
AUDIENCE: It's
the height for it.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So the water-- the height,
the water pressure.
All right, how about I?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] current.
AMY BANZAERT: Current, yep.
And current is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] amps.
AMY BANZAERT: Amps.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] flow.
AMY BANZAERT: And
the flow, yeah.
And that analogy is easy.
You can think of it as the flow.
And then what's R?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: And
so that would be?
AUDIENCE: The resistor.
AMY BANZAERT: The ohms.
Yep, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the diameter of the exit.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah so the pipe
exit diameter, et cetera, yeah.
So this is a handy
equation to know.
We don't have to do too
much EE in this class,
but you definitely have to do.
Electricity always bugged
me because it's invisible.
And as a mechanical
engineer, I don't really
enjoy thinking about
things that are invisible.
So I think it's
tough, and, yeah,
I like the flow
rate analogy a lot,
thinking about the
pressure and the water flow
and the resistance to that flow.
That helps me a lot.
So why am I reviewing
this to you?
What is useful about
these quantities?
So in this class, one is we
can predict battery life.
So batteries are measured
in amp hours, so how much
flow over how much time.
So you can know how
long your battery
is going to last, which is
really important when you're,
say, sizing a solar
system, a solar panel
system, or something like that.
Secondly, not destroying LEDs--
so I'm about to give
you an LED and a battery
and ask you to figure
out what size resistor
you need to connect the two and
then do a couple other things.
So let's review how to
calculate that really quickly.
Can anyone walk me through it?
AUDIENCE: What's the
size of the battery?
AMY BANZAERT: So the
battery is a 9 volt.
AUDIENCE: Do we know which
current that we'd use?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah so the LED
is a 20-milliamp-hour LED.
What else do you need to know?
AUDIENCE: How long [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Hm?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, so
how long you're powering
it might be important.
In this case, it's a flashlight.
So it's something you're
going to turn on and off,
and you can probably
estimate how long you're
going to need it.
The voltage, you're
actually going to need,
so it's a 3.6-volt LED.
Does anyone know
what LED stands for?
AUDIENCE: Light-Emitting Diode.
AMY BANZAERT: And does
anyone know what a diode is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It's essentially
a one-way pathway
in which [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So, essentially,
it's a one-way gate.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, so it's
absolutely a one-way gate,
and the light-emitting
diodes happen
to emit light when the
current passes through,
which is really handy.
So the one-way thing is
really important to remember.
When you're
connecting everything,
if it's not working,
that's a hint.
You'll notice that I drew
this LED with one leg longer
than the other.
That's because
that's how they come,
and that's a hint as to what
direction you should put them.
So you can do that
by trial and error,
but once you figure
it out, then you
can write down the longer
leg, what direction that
needs to go in.
So we know that our battery
is a 9-volt battery.
Awesome.
We know that our LED requires
20 milliamp hours and 3.6 volts.
And we know we've
got this equation.
And I told you that
you need a resistor.
So we're probably
looking at what
we want the resistor to be.
So what do we do from here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you know that
you have the remaining
voltage that you need to drop
before the circuit finishes
off.
So we need to drop off that
much V in your resistor.
And you know what the current
is in the resistor in milliamps,
so is that it?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, exactly.
Are there any questions?
So, OK, cool.
So I'll explain the
assignment, but that's
going to be very useful.
All right, so that would
be another reason why
you need to use that information
is if you don't use a resistor,
you're going to blow your
LED, and you only get one.
So you don't want to blow it.
Power is equal to the
voltage times the current.
That's another useful one.
Does this look like
any other equation
you might have seen in a
mechanics-- more oriented
mechanics, what
power is equal to?
AUDIENCE: I squared R.
AMY BANZAERT: I squared R?
Is that what you said?
AUDIENCE: No, [INAUDIBLE]
would be heat, right?
Like, power [INAUDIBLE]
would be heat.
So VI just reminded me of
the eat equation [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, absolutely.
And it does indeed
equal I square R.
But in terms of mechanical,
power and work are?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] over time.
AMY BANZAERT: Is
it over the time?
Yeah, exactly.
So I had to remind
myself, so I just froze.
But, yeah, so power is--
what's another way of
thinking about power?
AUDIENCE: Work over time.
AMY BANZAERT: Work
over time, yeah.
And what's work?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Say again?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] joules.
AMY BANZAERT: Yep,
and what's a joule?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Say again?
AMY BANZAERT: A newton-meter.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Say again?
AUDIENCE: Over time.
AMY BANZAERT:
Exactly, over time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: So-- excuse me?
AUDIENCE: Force velocity.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, exactly.
So however you get
to it, power is
equal to force times velocity,
and so which it's annoying
because we only have so many
letters in the English language
to work with.
But this velocity is
different from that voltage.
But you can think of
the voltage as a force,
like pressure, and
the I like a current,
sort of like a velocity.
And so that's how to
get back to relating
the mechanical side of things to
the electronic side of things.
And something they never told
me until I got to grad school
is all these equations you
use in electrical engineering
and all the equations you use
mechanical engineering are all
based on the same formulas
when you go back far
enough in the physics.
And so we're all just
talking about the same stuff.
We're just using
different assumptions
and different variables.
So if you're more comfortable
in the mechanical world,
figure out what it is
in the electrical world
and do the translation in
your mind or vice versa.
It's a nice trick.
If these are totally
unfamiliar concepts.
These are two books
that I posted on Stellar
that I would
recommend grabbing out
of the library to be
a refresher, starting
with the Scherz book.
So a lot of this
class, we're going
to do estimation because it's
a really handy tool for doing
work in developing countries
and as engineers and everywhere.
So we're going to start
with how to estimate
the energy in that
9-volt battery
that I'm about to give you
that we just talked about.
So here's the 9-volt battery.
And how do we estimate
the energy stored in it?
AUDIENCE: That's how long
it would power a flashlight.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, how
long to power something
like a flashlight.
So let's go down that path.
So what do we need to think
about in order to figure out--
so the reason I
put that underscore
there is just because you could
think about how long it takes
to power something
else if you know
that better than a flashlight.
But, yeah, this is a really
good way to think about that.
So what do we need to think
about in order to know that?
So how long does a
9-volt battery power
your flashlight for?
AUDIENCE: It's-- you need
to know how much power
the flashlight [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah so how could
we get a rough number for that?
AUDIENCE: It's less--
it should be less
than a light bulb [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: OK, but
it's still a light bulb.
AUDIENCE: The light
bulb [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: So a
small light bulb.
So we are powering
a little light bulb.
So what do you think that
light bulb might be rated at?
Hm?
AUDIENCE: 20 watts.
AMY BANZAERT: 20 watts.
Anyone else have a
different thought?
AUDIENCE: 10.
AMY BANZAERT: 10?
All right, so generally
in estimation, you
go with orders of
magnitude, like
we're talking about before.
So if you know specifically that
you're using a 20-watt light
bulb, put that 2 in.
But if you don't, just
go with 10 or 1 or 100.
And then, hopefully,
the small digits
will cancel each other out.
But in estimations,
we're never trying--
at this level,
we're never trying
to get to an actual
exact number that you're
going to use in a
specific equation
that you're going to use to
actually design a flashlight.
You're just trying to get
an order of magnitude.
Can I power a flashlight or
can I power this light bulb
with a voltmeter
battery, or do I
need a bigger battery,
type of thing.
So let's go with 10 watts.
So we know the flashlight
or the light bulb is 10.
We think the light
bulb is 10 watts.
What's next?
Someone else.
[LAUGHS] No, you're doing great.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
amount of time it takes.
AMY BANZAERT: OK, yeah, yeah.
So let's multiply it by time.
And then what will we have?
AUDIENCE: Energy
[INAUDIBLE] multiplied.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah,
we'll have our energy.
Awesome.
So how long does
your flashlight last?
AUDIENCE: 10 hours.
AMY BANZAERT: 10 hours?
So what happens if I do this?
What's wrong?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, my
units have been totally off.
So 10 hours.
So what units do I want?
AUDIENCE: Seconds.
AMY BANZAERT:
Yeah, so 60 minutes
per hour times 60
seconds per minute
is 3,600 times 10 times 10.
So what are my units now?
AUDIENCE: Joules.
AMY BANZAERT: Joules, yeah.
Awesome.
So does that sound good?
So 36 kilojoules.
When I did this, the
way I did it is I've
never had a flashlight
that uses a 9-volt battery.
I only have flashlights that
run on D cells or AA cells
or whatever.
So I didn't really
have a good sense
of how long my light bulb
would last on 10 hours.
And so I estimated that--
well, first, I thought
about how a battery works.
And how does a battery
work in really simple
10-year-old terms?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, so
there's a chemical reaction,
which requires chemicals,
which are volume based, right?
Like, you can
change the layering
of the different plates
that you need in a battery.
But fundamentally,
you can only have
so many chemicals in a battery.
So I thought about it like two
AAs is about the same volume,
and so it's equivalent.
And then, therefore, I said, all
right, well, my flashlights--
I forget how long I
thought they lasted.
I thought my bulb
was actually 5 watts,
so I cheated and put 5 in
there instead of a 10 or a 1.
I thought it lasted
just an hour.
So I got this many
joules, which I
believe is actually closer to
how long a 9-volt will last,
depending on how
good your 9-volt is.
So you can see, but
you guys are still
in the same order of
magnitude, so we're golden.
It doesn't really matter,
but just to give you
a slightly different approach.
So now let's try to
talk about estimation.
So why am I bugging you to
do this in an energy class?
So one is that it's really
handy when you're in a meeting,
say, with a community partner.
And community
partner says, I want
you to install me a solar
panel, and my roof is this big,
and I want it to power all
the ovens for my kitchen.
You might be able to very
quickly, rather than saying,
I don't know, or
that sounds stupid,
you might be able to very
quickly do the equations
and say, actually,
you'd need a solar panel
the size of a football
field to make that work.
So let's think of
a different method.
It's a really good way to gut
check your work or your others'
work, so other people's work.
So if you read in a newspaper
that someone's come up
with a new magic energy source
that does this amazing stuff,
you can really quickly check and
see, does this make any sense,
or is the reporter not
doing due diligence?
Or when you come up with
an answer on a homework set
or design problem, find it out.
And then also saving
time and money
that you don't have to spend
the time to figure out that--
spec that whole solar system
that that community partner
wanted before you've
actually figured out,
is the solar panel going
to work at all for you?
Estimation tends to
feel really hard,
and that's really legitimate.
So there's a lot of reasons
that that's the case.
One is that you're used to
problem sets, where there's
generally a right answer, and
exams, where there's generally
a right answer.
Certainly, that was
true in high school
and often is true even at MIT.
And in estimation there's
kind of a right answer,
but there's a lot of
different assumptions
you can make that could give
you a lot of different right
answers.
You're also used
to defined realms,
where you know you're
going to be given a test,
and it's going to test
you on these 10 equations
and how to use them
in these five realms,
and that's all you need to know.
And this is out of
that comfort zone
and totally in a
different space.
You typically have no
resources beyond your brain,
so, yes, we have Google.
You can always use that.
But in this class,
we're often going
to be doing it with no Google.
And so all you
have is your brain.
And so it's nice to be able to
lean on a textbook or Google
or whatever.
It's often in public.
So there's little time,
there's little warning.
That can be terrifying.
You'll see me screw up.
You may screw up.
It's hard.
But it's really worthwhile,
as I talked before.
Again, it's open-ended.
It's ill-defined.
There's multiple acceptable
methods and answers.
The significant
uncertainty-- is a light bulb
actually 5 watts or 10
watts or 1 watt or bigger?
It's hard to know exactly
if you can't actually
look at the light bulb,
and that can be stressful.
And then you have to
have the set of knowledge
that you don't just know values
or quantities or relationships,
but you know all of them
in relation to each other,
and that is a lot of knowledge.
So that's one of
the reasons that I'm
trying to push you to have
these units at your fingertips
as well as having
some quantities,
like how much is an
apple, things like that,
so that you're
going to be better
at estimation because
part of it is practice,
and practice is huge, and we're
going to be doing that a ton.
And the only way to get
decent at it is to practice.
But part of it is
having those quantities
in your head already so that
some of that uncertainty
disappears.
So what are the actions
that you can take
to do effective estimation?
So identifying a problem
system-- so that generally
involves drawing these pictures.
So I drew my
battery, then I know
it needs to power a light bulb,
and I know they're connected.
And that is a good way
just to think about it.
Drawing your system always seems
to help in problem solving.
Identifying a quantity
within a system--
so in this case, we identified
that there's a battery,
and it's 9 volts.
And we identified a 10-watt
or 5-watt light bulb.
Providing a value
for the quantity--
so I kind of combined
those two, right?
But you could think,
all right, I need
to know the voltage for this.
I need to know the
wattage for that
and then think about what it is.
And then also with time,
we really did that.
We thought about time,
and then we figured out
what it needed to be.
Counting a set of things.
So I'm trying to think
of a good example
for counting a set of things.
So, for example, if you're
estimating how many seats there
are in 10 to 50, you could count
a row and then multiply, right?
Or if you're estimating how
many light bulbs in a kilowatt,
you count one, and
then you multiply.
Comparing two systems
for a quantity-- so
I compared my AAs to
a 9 volt because I'm
more comfortable thinking
in AAs than I am in 9 volts.
Every time you do that, you're
making another assumption.
It's a little risky,
but it's better
than doing nothing by far.
Identifying a relationship
between quantities-- so
we did that.
Power times rate is energy.
And then we have
changing a system scope.
So that's what I did
getting from 9 volts to AAs
and identifying
a similar system.
Oh, I guess scope
could also be--
or similar system could be
thinking about this chemically.
Like, you could skip all
these energy equations.
And if you are a
chemist and really
comfortable with
chemistry, you could just
figure out the chemical
reaction and do it that way.
I'm not a chemist, so that's
not the way I'm going to pick,
but it would be
another approach.
And then, as I
mentioned, practice.
OK, so now we're going to do
a harder estimation together,
and then we're going to
take a break because I
know three hours is an
incredibly long time
to sit on uncomfortable chairs
in a poorly laid-out classroom.
So how do you want to
approach this bicycle problem?
AUDIENCE: Should
we put [INAUDIBLE]??
AMY BANZAERT: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: The caption.
AMY BANZAERT: Oh, yeah, yeah.
So this says, "Estimate
the drag force
on a bicycle and rider
traveling at 20 miles per hour."
And I gave you a little help.
That's 9 meters per second.
AUDIENCE: By drag, do you mean
the wind as well as the ground
[INAUDIBLE] friction?
AMY BANZAERT: So what
do you think is bigger?
AUDIENCE: The ground.
AMY BANZAERT: You think
the ground is bigger?
AUDIENCE: He's traveling
at 9 meters per second.
AMY BANZAERT: Does anyone
have a different approach?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: So I think the
wind is going to dominate.
And so you could include
the wheel friction.
But in an estimation,
you want to just look
at your biggest quantity.
So I'm going to say we
can neglect that friction
and just focus on the drag
associated with that body going
against the wind.
And this is a
question last year.
This is just a
silly-looking bicycle.
That's why I posted it,
because I find it amazing.
But we don't need to worry about
whether the person is facing
the wind this way or this way.
We can assume the body--
you can neglect that,
worrying about that.
So what do we need
to think about?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] surface
area of the [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, so we can
think about the surface area.
So how do you want
to model our person?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
a triangle.
AMY BANZAERT: All
right, so a triangle.
We can do a triangle.
We could do a rectangle.
The equation for
area of a rectangle
is a little bit
easier than a triangle
because you don't
have to divide by 2.
So let's go with
rectangle because it's
kind of meaningless.
So what's the area
of an average person?
AUDIENCE: Half a meter
squared [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: Half
a meter squared.
OK, great.
So we have our surface area.
Does anyone know how surface
area relates to drag force?
AUDIENCE: There's usually
a drag coefficient,
and you just want to
[INAUDIBLE] area [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: So
the drag force is
equal to a drag
coefficient times the area.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Say again?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
times velocity.
AMY BANZAERT: Times velocity.
Does anyone know that
drag coefficient?
So this might not be
the best approach.
All right, so this
was step one--
didn't work.
Or it's one that
we could go after,
but you're trying to
answer this question
right now in the classroom
without looking up that drag
coefficient.
And we don't have
any people who've
been spending too much
time on fluid mechanics,
so we're going to have to go
a different approach, which
is great.
So what would be a
different approach?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] density.
The density variable.
So kilograms per meter cubed.
So if you know how many--
the volume [INAUDIBLE]
flow that's [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: So we have
kilograms per meter cubed.
So you're saying to multiply it
by area to get kilograms from--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: Multiply by
the velocity [INAUDIBLE]
the volume metric.
AMY BANZAERT: Mhm.
So I think we're
actually here, still.
So now we're getting at
an equation that actually
has the right units, so
that's great because we've
added in the density.
And we could say that
this is just a constant,
and we're doing an estimation,
and so we can neglect it.
So absolutely, this
would be one way.
So let's work it out.
So does anyone know
the density of air?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: It's
basically 1, yep.
And then we have our area
is 1/2, and velocity is 9.
So that's basically 5.
5 whats?
Forces in?
AUDIENCE: Newtons.
AMY BANZAERT:
Yeah, so 5 newtons.
So how can you gut
check if 5 newtons
sounds like a good number?
OK, so what is a newton?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: An
apple, all right.
So we're talking about
the weight of five apples.
When you ride on a bike
at 20 miles an hour,
is that fast or slow on a bike?
AUDIENCE: It's fast.
AUDIENCE: Fast.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: It's
pretty decent, yeah.
So how many people have
ridden a bike before?
All right, awesome.
So this is-- we're getting
into familiar territory, great.
So when you're riding
on a bike, does it
feel like it could be
5 newtons on your body?
Five apples?
OK, so if I said, could it
be 500 apples, would you--
that's ridiculous.
If I said, like, zero apples,
you'd probably say, no.
You're feeling something
against your body.
So maybe we're in
the right realm.
Cool.
Great.
So good job.
A lot of people give
up on this approach
because you can't remember
that constant or whatever.
Or you're missing
a term in this one
because we need
that row in there.
But this one worked.
The way I do it, the
way I approached it,
is I thought about the power
associated with bike riding.
So when I bike at
the Z Center, it
tells me actually how
much work I'm doing,
how much power I'm generating.
And so I'm kind of
a terrible biker.
You can tell I'm a
little out of shape.
But I know that I
can bike somewhere
on the order of 200 watts.
And so that means
I'm all set, right?
Because now I have
that and now I just
need my 9 meters per second.
And what am I doing wrong?
That's what I'm doing wrong.
I need to divide.
[LAUGHS] And so then I
get about 20 newtons.
Is that right?
Did I do that math right?
Sorry, board fatigue.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: What?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
that's about right.
AMY BANZAERT: Thank you.
Yeah, I know I'm not
actually dividing 9.
I'm dividing 10 because
when it's estimation,
it doesn't matter.
So we're kind of in the
same order of magnitude.
We're a little different.
But this is a nice
approach because it's just
two quantities
and all you really
have to think about is one.
And this 200 watts is
actually ambitious for biking
for a long period.
That's a lot of power
you're outputting.
AUDIENCE: How did you
know it was 200 watts?
AMY BANZAERT: Because--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
AMY BANZAERT: --you actually
see it on the screen.
And some people who
are really into biking,
like what Lance
Armstrong can do and what
a normal person can do, yeah.
So this is just
a nice way to see
there's two different
approaches to this problem.
And I'm sure there's others
that you could go after too.
So there's always another way.
Estimate how high a
D cell can lift you,
and if you have a background
that's not engineering based,
if you can find
someone who is, that
might be good to have the mix
rather than two nonengineers
working together on this,
though you guys may do fine too.
So it's worth a shot.
So, yeah, so take 10 minutes
to work on that problem.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
OK, does every
team have a guess?
Does any team not have a guess?
Or can you raise your
hand if you have a guess?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: OK, great.
So did anyone have a
hundredth of a meter?
Tenth?
A meter?
10 meters?
So maybe a 16.
100 meters?
4.
1,000?
10,000?
OK, so we're pretty constrained.
How do these numbers strike
you, as reasonable, ridiculous?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Ridiculous.
AMY BANZAERT: OK,
so, but there's
an aspect to this that's
ridiculous, period.
The question is a
little funny, right?
We can talk about that.
So can someone go through
how they got 10, order of 10?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So
basically what we did
was we did the same thing
that you did earlier.
We thought about
how long a D cell
could power a 10-watt bulb.
And--
AMY BANZAERT: OK, so you
have your D cell system.
AUDIENCE: Right.
AMY BANZAERT: How
long, or let's do time
to last for a 10-watt bulb.
AUDIENCE: Right.
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
AUDIENCE: And we came up with
a number that, when we solved,
we got 15,000 joules
as the energy.
And then, basically,
we equated it
with the potential
energy of a person
weighing roughly 50
kilograms at a height x.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So that would be mgh.
So that'd be 50 into 10 into x.
And that would be
equated to 15,000.
And then you solve for x,
and x turns out to be 30.
AMY BANZAERT: OK, did anyone
take a different approach?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: I kind of led
you guys down to this approach,
given the previous
exercises, so I'm not shocked
that no one did.
For the people who
got closer to 100,
what was the assumption that was
different that led you to 100
rather than order
of magnitude 10?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Our battery, we put in
that it had 180,000 joules, not
[INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: 180,000 joules?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMY BANZAERT: And where
did that number come from?
AUDIENCE: 10 watts for 5 hours.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMY BANZAERT: So you guessed
10 watts times 5 hours
got you there.
So it was really
just because I think
you guys had 10 watts
too, so it's just,
how long does it last?
15,000 joules is about
what the 9 volt lasted for.
And how does the volume of a
D cell compare to a 9 volt?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: So I would say
a D cell is actually maybe
50% bigger.
So I think 180,000
might be impressive,
but 15,000 is a little
low, but we're all pretty
close to the same ballpark.
And I actually think that
we're closer to 100 than 10,
depending on the
assumptions you make.
But everyone did great
with these results.
So why isn't there an
awesome personless lifter
powered by a D cell
out there so we can all
get to the top of our
roofs to shovel them off
or whatever you need to do?
You probably not
shoveling your dorm rooms,
but I sure need to shovel my
roof if I could get up there.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Efficiency.
AMY BANZAERT: Efficiency, yup.
AUDIENCE: It's also
instantaneous, right?
You're assuming that
the battery [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: Well,
not necessarily.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: I didn't
say how much time it took.
AUDIENCE: That's true.
AMY BANZAERT: So yeah, so there
are some efficiency issues.
But this exercise
would actually run
in a classical 2.009, which
is the senior mechanical
engineering design class.
And a guy called
Nate Ball came up--
oh, I'm clicking on
the wrong computer--
with what he calls the
Atlas Powered Rope Ascender
that basically does this.
Of course, there are
some efficiency losses,
so it's not actually a D cell.
It's a much better battery.
But it's in kind of
the same ballpark.
And so it's kind of amazing
because you wouldn't think
that a D cell would have a
chance of lifting you anything,
right?
But the embodied energy in a D
cell is actually pretty good.
And at the same
time, I'm telling you
that I also showed
you that graph
where I told you a battery is
lousy compared to gasoline.
So it's good in some
respects, but it's also lousy
if you actually wanted to
save power in an automobile
with a D cell versus a person
lifting up a little bit.
An automobile requires a
whole lot more energy to work.
OK, so finally, after
all this other stuff,
we can talk about the class now.
Now you have a sense of what
the class is going to be like.
So I'm Amy Banzaert.
I have a three-year-old.
His name is Eli.
I do work in
developing countries,
mostly on charcoal, which
you'll hear about later.
Our TA is Amit Gandhi.
Where are you there?
AMIT GANDHI: I went to Brazil.
AMY BANZAERT: Where?
AMIT GANDHI: I went
to Brazil [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: I don't
know how I share this.
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah.
So I went to Brazil.
And I've [INAUDIBLE] time
working in Ghana, Guatemala,
and Brazil before.
AMY BANZAERT: We have a bunch
of other staff who are helping.
Dennis Nagle works downstairs.
He's the shop manager for D-Lab.
Steve Banzaert,
who you may notice
the last name is
disturbingly similar,
is, in fact, my husband, he's
also really good at EE stuff.
So he helped teams last year,
and he'll do that again.
Ken McEnaney is a mechanical
engineering grad student.
Sarah Reed just finished
her master's here
in Mech E, is really
good in design work.
And then Amelia Servi,
also a mechanical engineer.
Because this is a
design class, we're
kind of slanted toward
mechanical engineering support.
And then we'll probably
add a few other mentors
along the way.
So our syllabus--
so if you guys want
to break out your
syllabus, you now
know who's going
to help everyone.
You can read the aims
and the objectives,
which I have worked
pretty hard to make sure
that everything
we're doing aligns
with those aims and objectives.
So that should give
you a good sense
of what you can hope to
come out of the class with.
And if those don't
align with what
your hopes are for
the class, maybe this
isn't the right class for you.
And if they do, awesome,
I'm glad to have you.
So this is a 12-unit
class, which means,
hypothetically, you're spending
six hours a week in class
and six hours a
week out of class,
working on all the activities
associated with the class.
And last year was
a 9-unit class,
and students said-- it
was very much 9 units.
And they said there was
not nearly enough time
to do everything they wanted to
do in the class, which is why
we bumped it up to 12 units.
So I think it is reasonable
to expect you'll be spending
six hours a week out of class.
And this is a class where
attendance is expected.
So I know there's a
lot of classes at MIT
where you can skip the lectures
and the labs, or at least
the lectures, and do OK.
In this class, like those
estimation exercises,
you can't really capture what
we did in the lecture notes.
And so you'll miss the learning
entirely if you don't show up.
So there is a strong
punishment in terms of grades
if you don't show up to class
without a really good reason
why not in terms of grades
being reduced for those reasons.
There are two quizzes that
happen in the beginning
half of the term just
on the material covered
in the class, the labs,
and the assignments,
as well as assignments,
PSETs, lab stuff.
Everything should be
turned on via Stellar
unless it's something
that can't physically
be turned in electronically.
Last year, I had issues
with stuff getting lost,
and so this is my hope
that nothing will get lost.
So just make sure it
makes it on Stellar,
and hopefully Stellar
won't disappoint.
Are there any grad students?
OK, so if you want
G-level credit as opposed
to undergrad credit,
you need to sign up
for a different subject number.
So just you can talk to
me afterwards and just
send me an email, telling
me that you're signing up
for the grad class because,
if I don't know that,
I will not be able to tell
the person who actually writes
in your grade the
right grade, and then
you'll get an F without
me even knowing that,
and that would stink.
So, yeah.
Most of the readings
are going to be
handed out online, basically.
So while there is a
required text, which
I think is a great text, of
Paul Polak's Out of Poverty,
it's totally something that
you can borrow from a friend
or grab from the
library because it's not
like we're referring
to it every week
and you need to have it heavily
highlighted and in your grasp
at all times like you would
a math textbook or something.
But Paul is a good
guy, so if you
can afford the book,
which is, like, $14,
it's worth supporting him.
So the structure
of the class is--
the first half of the class
is lecture and lab heavy.
It's sort of like a normal
class, where, like today, I'll
be doing talking, probably
not as much talking
as I've done today ever again.
We try to do a lot of hands-on
exercises in class too.
But there will be a
decent bit of talking.
And then the labs, which
are very hands on and run
by Amit, where we
build a biodigester,
we build a solar panel
out of solar cells,
we build a little, tiny wind
turbine, you make charcoal,
you do all stuff that's very
hands on, relevant to what
we might be doing in Nicaragua.
And then subsequently
over spring break,
most people travel to
Nicaragua with the class,
which is a really
fabulous experience.
That's extracurricular.
It's not a requirement of
the class to go to Nicaragua,
but it does add a lot
to your experience.
Actually working
with real people
rather than them just
being hypothetical
is a pretty valuable addition.
And then after the
trip, you come back,
and it's very much
a design class,
where you're working on a
project identified in Nicaragua
or really identified
beforehand that you
learn more about in Nicaragua.
And then you work on it for
the last half of the class.
The lab and lectures
basically disappear,
and it's all just work time
with a little bit of lecture
content to help you
with the design process.
So that part is
pretty intensive.
And then you do
final presentations.
We hand off the projects to
Nicaragua one way or another,
and the class is over.
So that's how it's split up.
What else?
One thing to know is, for people
who are going to Nicaragua,
it's really helpful to
speak a bit of Spanish.
And so one of the more
random homework assignments
is to at least listen
to a couple of podcasts
per week of a Spanish podcast,
like Spanish learning podcast,
so that you can at least
say "hi" and "thank you"
and things like that.
If you happen to speak
Spanish already, bonus.
And if you're fluent,
no need to practice.
But if you're not, it's nice
to get a little practice.
If you've taken like Spanish
II or something in high school,
it's nice to practice a little
because that stuff tends
to come back quickly if you
practice and not if you don't.
And I will start speaking
a little bit of Spanglish.
I have taken all of
Spanish I at MIT,
so I am not your Spanish expert.
But I have spent, by now over
the course of different weeks,
probably a couple of
months in Nicaragua.
So my Spanish is
a bit better when
I talk about technical things
than I know about in Spanish
than just general conversation.
But, yeah, so I'm not expecting
you to be a Spanish expert
through a technical class
because that would be
ludicrous, and I'm not, myself.
But it is helpful to know a
little bit of the language.
Finally, just one thing is one
of the things you picked up
is a Muddy card, which
you may or may not
have encountered at MIT.
And it's just a way
to give feedback
to me about what
you understood, what
you valued about the class, what
you didn't understand, hated,
completely anonymously.
And it allows me to improve
my teaching in the class.
I am finishing up my PhD.
I aspire to be a professor.
So I really want to improve and
appreciate your help in that
and appreciate
constructive criticism.
It doesn't even have to
be that constructive.
It's useful for me, and it's
anonymous, so you can be blunt.
Or if there's something you
love, it's great to hear
that too, just to know
what to keep in the class.
But I really appreciate you
taking the time to do that.
And then we also have similar
stuff with the readings,
just getting feedback
online on the forums.
Do you guys have any
questions about the syllabus
and what I just went over?
OK, cool.
So in order to get
into the class,
because it is a class where
you get to travel to Nicaragua,
there's a big commitment
in terms of we're
working with real
people in Nicaragua.
And so we want to make sure
that you're here to really work
and not just to fill out your
class requirements or whatever.
We do have a strict
"what you have to do."
So one is a student
profile, where you just
tell me about yourself.
That's online,
linked to on Stellar.
And the other thing
is a DIY lantern.
So I'm going to give you all
an LED and a 9-volt battery.
You can pick up a
resistor, and you
need to figure out what resistor
you need from the Edgerton
Center, and this
is all online too.
But it's room 4409.
This is the combo.
The resistors are on
your right, so you
need to figure out
what your resistor is.
I would recommend checking
that the resistor you pull out
of the drawer is actually the
right resistor by looking up
the resistor code and doing
the work because the Edgerton
Center is a student lab, and so
resistors tend to get mixed up.
And if you pick a
wildly wrong resistor,
you will blow your LED, or
your device won't work at all.
But on the flip side,
the V equals IR equation,
in terms of how flexible an
LED is, is relatively flexible.
So if you can't find
the exact resistor
you've calculated the value
for, go up or down 10% or 15%,
and you'll be fine.
So anyway, so you're trying
to build a lantern out
of found materials, that
resistor, the 9-volt battery,
and the LED.
And what I care about
is, does it function?
So does it turn on?
Is it possible to
turn it on and off?
And can I figure out that switch
in a reasonable amount of time?
Aesthetics-- does
it look decent?
Did you use
materials creatively?
So if you found a
lantern at EMS or REI
tonight and bought it and
just swapped out the internals
with this, that would not
be a very creative use
of found materials.
So I'm hoping that
you actually find
stuff that's recycled rather.
And then maximizing
light-- is it actually
useful as a lantern?
So those are the criteria.
And you can bring
the lantern back
to just the room down the hall.
It's E34-211.
And just placed it on a
desk with a piece of paper
that has your name, a really
quick sketch of the lantern
so that we remember what it is
when we give the lanterns back
to you, and just a
really fast explanation
of how you sized
the resistor so we
know that you understand
that aspect of what we just
went over.
Are there any questions
about this assignment?
AUDIENCE: What do you
mean by materials?
[INAUDIBLE]?
AMY BANZAERT: Found materials.
AUDIENCE: Are we just
supposed to have an LED
or construct
something [INAUDIBLE]??
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: An LED's
[INAUDIBLE],, right?
AMY BANZAERT: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
covering or something
[INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: That would
be one way to do it, yeah.
AUDIENCE: But it's going
to be materials [INAUDIBLE]
other than that, or?
AMY BANZAERT: So I'm sure
you can find some materials
downstairs.
Downstairs, there's a--
not in the engine lab.
The engine lab, you
can just get resistors.
And we actually
intentionally tried
to make this class a little
short so there's time
to help you start this project.
So downstairs, there's
the D-Lab shop.
And there's some scrap materials
in there that you can scrounge.
Or the recycling bins in
dorms, at least back when I was
a student here-- an
undergrad student--
were pretty full of wild
things that might be useful.
And MIT trash cans are amazing.
There's so much
there, just walking
the halls, where people
have piles of stuff
that they're throwing out.
There's all sorts of
stuff that you can grab.
But, yeah, the idea is to
just use found materials
because when you're
in the field,
you're often just looking
around in the trash heaps.
And, yes, the trash heaps
in developing countries
and some regions are really
more useful than in other places
than here for getting trash.
People are also more
creative, so they
tend to use up all their trash,
so there's not much left.
So it's a trade-off.
So in some respects, we
have worse trash piles,
and in other respects, we
have better trash piles.
But the idea is
to make a lantern
with trash and the
components that I give you.
Do you have any other
questions about it?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can we use other
electronic components,
like a switch?
Or do we just get creative
for those as well?
AMY BANZAERT: So you have
a design trade-off here.
I want it to function,
which might push you
toward using a switch.
And I want you to
be creative, which
might push you toward
using something that
isn't a traditional switch.
And that's really your call.
And so if you decide that
the switch is the right call
because you're going
to value functionality,
maybe you do
something else that's
a creative use of materials
in a different realm
so that you try to
meet all things.
But in every design
process, there's
going to be direct conflicts.
And I need it to be
super lightweight,
and I need to have
a huge battery pack.
That's a classic
design conflict,
and I'm trying to
reproduce that here.
AUDIENCE: And we
can just pick up
a switch from the project lab?
AMY BANZAERT: No.
AUDIENCE: No?
So you can only
pick up [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: A resistor.
So I will hand you out an LED
and a 9-volt battery right now.
Actually, Amit, if
you want to do that.
And then you can
get the resistor
from the Edgerton Center,
and everything else
is found materials.
So the homework for this week is
this reading, which is online--
write a reaction piece.
The instructions for how
to write a reaction piece,
which is a paragraph--
it's not onerous--
is on the Stellar forum.
And then there's a problem
set with two problems on it
that's also on Stellar.
Mhm?
AUDIENCE: This is due next week?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So once we find
out that we're in the class.
AMY BANZAERT:
Right, so I will let
you know if you're in the
class by midnight tomorrow.
So that gives you plenty
of time to do the homework
after you find out.
But, conveniently,
fewer people showed up
than said they were
going to show up,
so the ratio of people getting
in should be pretty good.
So, yeah, so if you guys
can take five minutes
to do the Muddy cards, I
would really appreciate it.
And then you can leave,
you can head downstairs,
and look for found materials.
You can talk to me right
now, whatever you want.